we've got two stories here that i wanna
i wanna talk about the first is from
kutv
utah-based zion's bank ops out of
participating in boise pride festival
this was over child drag shows and
zion's bank issued a statement saying
when we sponsored this we did not know
that they were putting minors in these
kind of situations and then boise pride
says oh miners have always been involved
and it's like that doesn't that's not
better
but this is interesting because it's
showing that a corporation is saying
we're going to lose money if we go this
route so let's not do it but at the same
time we have another story
game gaming charity games done quick
cancels florida event citing covid and
don't say gay law
so
i don't know what is this florida is
losing games done quick because of they
wouldn't have masks and because of quote
unquote don't say gay the parental
writes an education bill that's a false
statement don't say gay i like to call
that bill they don't say straight
because it has the same effect and then
over in utah we're seeing a bank
cancel their support for a pride event
so i i don't know it's just it's is that
at first i was thinking the zions bank
thing was a victory for the cultural
right in that companies are finally
being like hey that's the line for us
and we won't do it but you're also
seeing companies pull out of florida so
it's kind of like maybe it's just the
culture is bifurcating why yeah i think
it's bifurcation why would
banks
be putting money into gay pride all
kinds dude i mean like they sponsor it
and then you see their logo and you're
like i need to get a mortgage and i'll
go to that bank and the same reason why
they would sponsor like a half marathon
or something like that just i genuinely
for profit it's because they're trying
to get exposure yeah not necessarily
because they like it although it's not
because they're trying to sew division
or anything but i wonder what happened
like what happened with zion's bank
where they were like hey you know
sponsoring the sexualization of children
probably is bad for our bottom line you
know what i mean i'm sure they just got
a bunch of calls
yeah and i know i don't know idaho power
did too according to chris ruffo they
also yeah they also made a similar
statement i think it's a win for the
cultural right because what you're
talking about about that gaming company
they've been doing that for a long time
they were doing that a few years ago
different companies the ncaa did it when
they wanted specific bathroom lives
boise prides its postponing child drag
show due to increased safety concerns no
i think it's because they're losing
money yeah see that's what they do it's
the same thing with the children's
hospital they turn it into see now the
story is not that children were involved
now the stories at the right is so
extreme and so radical they're
threatening so violent that they are
threatening the safety of children the
story is now
conservatives pounce and not that hey
we're enticing your kids to drag shows
this is always what they do i highly
doubt they're afraid for their safety
it's it's dangerous to think that
prevent attempting to prevent a child
from getting experimental surgery is the
danger
when right the experimental surgery
actually could be considered dangerous
yes yeah well it's either that or
they're going to be like oh the safety
threat is actually coming from the right
they're threatening our event so we have
to shut it down it shifts people's
outrage it shifts people's compassion
they forget what people were mad about
in the first place and like oh those
memes
clever this is clever what they're going
to do now
is they're going to say zion's bank
didn't just pull out they threatened us
with violence yeah they're going to say
the statement they put out was
stochastic terrorism and now we're
forced to shut our event down zion's
bank and the bank's going to be like we
didn't we didn't mean it we're so sorry
this is this is war they probably will
backtrack yeah i mean i think it's good
though that they came to pressure from
the right i mean if this is what it is
then this is what it is
i mean i wish it would the headline said
you know uh boise pride pulls event
after major funder pulls out or whatever
and you can go into like your backlash
because of child involvement like i
don't know that this is an accurate
headline and that bothers me purposeful
right totally purposeful and i think
that probably
the way that okay so
zion is probably a regional bank it
serves a lot of people in idaho i assume
maybe utah and people in those
communities don't like whatever boise
pride is doing they don't like the drag
shows right and in florida the gaming
company is saying we don't as a company
like this value so we're not going to
support here to me this is more
interesting the boise pride because it's
coming from the community people who
bank with this bank are saying hey i
don't like this i don't want to do it
whereas like i really don't think any of
the gaming customers i mean i would be
really surprised if the gaming customers
were like hey i'm gonna stop
you know attending your events or using
your service if you don't specifically
pull out of florida i think that is them
trying to pressure florida the same way
that the ncaa tried to pressure north
carolina uh when they said we're not
going to host um you know the ncaa
basketball i think it was like it would
think it was basketball that year uh
because that has a direct influence on
revenue it's a huge uh win for the state
i think you know republicans have a huge
opportunity in this midterm to have a
super majority if they campaigned
properly and i think the campaigning is
simple because a lot of people ask me
like how do i get through to my family
and friends they're too woke they don't
listen and i'm like
you don't argue with them
you feign interests like you know i
shouldn't say feign but like hear them
out and then you can simply respond with
yeah man you know trump he can be scary
but
i think the weird thing to me is all
these child sex change surgeries that
keep happening and then when they say
what do you what what are you talking
about be like i don't know i was just
reading something in like washington
post about children getting sex changes
oh my god it was weird show the picture
of the the 13 year
stitches across the chest are just this
right that's that's level two the first
point is just to say this is something
that i find odd and then don't fight
with them don't argue with them and if
they're like i don't you're talking
about be like oh i don't know here let
me show you and then just pull up the
article on child sex chain surgery and
then be like yeah here like they're
whatever i don't know are you and then
and then genuinely just don't be mean
don't be like it's wrong and you're
supporting it both you got to be like
i mean then you do what ian said you put
the picture and be like i don't know you
know look at this picture it'd be like
crazy that that i don't know i saw that
and i was just kind of like i don't know
what's going on anymore i had a i had a
guy a professor from st mary's on my
show and i had him on because he said
that the whole grooming thing us calling
people groomers on the left was a part
of an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
that had to do with q anon so i wanted
to have him on the show and ask him
about that
um and he claimed to be conservative
himself and claimed to be a christian
and so we kind of went back and forth
and i just like pulled up some articles
and was like do you support this here is
an example of a teacher ideologically
grammy and a kid do you support like
these teachers pressuring kindergartners
to use they them pronouns and just like
make them kind of answer for that of
course you're not going to be that
bombastic with a family member but once
they're met with those kind of specific
examples and they have to answer for
their support he very quickly backed up
and was like well no no no no no and
tried to kind of narrow his opposition
once you can kind of make them do that i
think you can make them realize what's
really going on yeah i think part of it
you also have to hear like what you have
to hear past what they are using as an
example to hear what the concern is
right if you hear
well donald trump is
terrible and he's aggressive and he's
rude and whatever else like if they
can't tie to example it's that donald
trump represents an ideology that is
different than what they're used to and
they're not going to be receptive if you
shout back at them you have to
understand where someone is coming from
my dad gets really loud his name is also
tim and he'll be like donald trump that
guy
and he's like getting loud and i'm just
thinking like
i'm so happy because he's communicating
with me that's all i care about at that
point i don't i'm just happy that he's
letting it out yeah you asked him why
he's so mad at trump next next time i
want to get deeper yeah last time my mom
was like oh kim you're getting angry and
he's like i'm not getting angry becky
i do think part of it is like people are
unwilling to have these conversations
because
we see uh discourse on uh things people
disagree about as so volatile most time
it's better not to have the conflict and
i think part of that is on you you have
to control how you react and keep
yourself accountable to being civil and
you know
talking with compassion as much as you
can about these issues while not just
compromising your viewpoint right like
you have to be honest about how you feel
i think so often people are afraid to
say like i actually don't agree with you
because they think the fallout will be
so bad and it doesn't have to be we need
more courage
you know i i i mentioned this before it
is not courageous for the people who
work here on this show to say our
opinions because we know we have a
company where our opinions you're
allowed to say right courageous is the
guy who works at a steel mill who speaks
up and says that courageous is the
person who works at a school who speaks
up and say it and says it and uh it's
tough but we need more people to stand
up and just be like hey man
the child sex change thing is a line too
far like i ain't going there i ain't
voting for those people
i if you can't that's the thing
if if you as a regular old american
cannot publicly say
i refuse to vote for child sex change
surgery
then we're they're screwed seriously
because because like like that story to
me was just like
yeah that's that's beyond the line you
know like for me i voted for trump
you know in 2020 for a variety of
reasons that did not broach children
getting sex change surgery now we're at
that point where i'm kind of like how
could any reasonable person
who agrees with us keep quiet now
knowing this stuff has been happening
children young girls some as young as 13
getting double mastectomies yeah
i mean i can tell you unfortunately i
spent a lot of time on white woman
instagram and liberal woman instagram
which is the worst place on earth and
you would be surprised at the number of
like suburban
kind of conservative christian moms who
buy
this idea that well it is compassionate
to allow kids to do this because they
might commit suicide or i don't have a
say in this their doctors their parents
know best or who believe in like the
propaganda about not being able to get
miscarriage care there's a lot of
misinformation it's what we were talking
about like that toxic empathy piece that
i think so many women especially
christian women are just totally
manipulated by they're just manipulated
by the maxims that trans women are
wisdom women and things like that and so
i i mean that's how they're drawn in
fake compassion toxic empathy it's
pretty easy to get people to believe
anything if you tell them that doing so
makes them sound like a good person you
mentioned toxic everything i think it's
fascinating did you do is that what you
wrote about in a book or was this just
something you've been focusing on well
that's yeah it's something it's not just
me it's something that a lot of i would
say like conservative christians have
been talking about for a long time
because there's such a problem of
progressivism within the the church and
it's this idea that we have to lead with
empathy we have to see with empathy we
have to discuss everything with empathy
i'm like look empathy has its place it
can be really good to be able to put
yourself in someone else's shoes but if
that's the only thing that you're doing
then you're going to make really stupid
decisions because you don't look at the
facts you don't look at what's true you
are partial in your judgment making
you're deferring to one person over the
other because you think it's
compassionate to do so and it's going to
make you make decisions that have really
bad consequences like open borders like
social justice crime policies because
you're told that's empathetic they have
deadly consequences i think that there
are a lot of women and maybe you would
know more about this from your social
media stalking but i think there are a
lot of women who fear being bad moms and
doing wrong by their child and so it's
easy to then say like
well if their doctor says it's a good
idea to do this i'll just commit to this
lifestyle because i don't want them to
ever look back and be like you're the
one who made me suicidal you're the one
who made me depressed well sure and
abigail schreier would definitely say
there are people like that but it's more
the women who go along with it their
kids aren't involved but you know who
just go along with it but they want
their kids to have the friends well
they're more concerned about how other
moms see that yeah yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there